we are joined tonight by the director of
the centers for disease control and
prevention dr rachelle wolinski doctor
thanks for joining us
thanks for having me back brent good
evening
good evening we have a lot of questions
a lot of viewers questions as well that
i'll play for you but i want to start
with
when did you realize did you know that
omicron was going to spread this quickly
obviously you had the travel ban back in
november
from south africa
but when did you realize it was going to
be this
yeah you know
things are moving quickly and i know
people are concerned so maybe we'll just
step back reiterate we now are seeing
omicron in about 73
um in our projections of what we have
right now and in some areas of the
country as you noted the areas are 90
percent omicron but this pace um the
speed by which omicron has
been you know transmitting has been seen
and mirrored in many other countries and
so we've been watching this carefully we
anticipated this this is what we have
been preparing for there have been
doubling times of this virus in other
countries that have had the virus before
us in the one and a half to three day
range and so this is exactly what we
anticipated and it is why the president
has been moving forward and today
announced a three-pronged plan to
increase support and surge capacity in
hospitals to
increase access to free tests and to
make sure that there's increased
capacity for both vaccinations and for
boost
okay importantly i think it's probably
you mentioned the president
go ahead
if i
yeah i was gonna say importantly if i
really do want to say we're in a very
different position now than we were just
a year ago because now we have the
science we have the tools that we need
in order to combat this pandemic and and
that and even the omicron variant and
that includes getting vaccinated getting
boosted and then you know practicing all
those prevention measures that we've
been talking about and even for
vaccinated and boosted people that
includes wearing a mask in public indoor
settings
you know there's a lot of concern about
testing that people can't get testing
and i know what the president said today
and what's going to be implemented in
the first of the year about the 500
million tests here is the president back
in december
of last year and the president today
take a listen we need to scale up
testing so anyone who needs one can get
a test
after 10 months of the pandemic we still
don't have enough testing
that's a travesty culvert
is
spreading
so rapidly if you notice
it just it just happened almost
overnight i don't think anybody
anticipated that this was going to be as
rapidly spreading as it did
now doctor you said that you were
prepared and you did anticipate omicron
spreading as rapidly as it did if that's
the case why wasn't testing
ramped up from december of 2020 if it
was a travesty back then why isn't it a
travesty now
so let me just be clear that
when we learned about omicron at the end
of november and we started seeing what
was happening in other countries that is
when we anticipated how quickly it could
in fact transmit but let me say we
recognize that there is a huge demand
right now not only just in the united
states but around the world for tests
and the government is taking action and
we recognize we have more work to do so
as you know the president announced
three billion dollars to rapid tests and
500 million rapid tests soon to be
available but also we have 20 000 free
pcr testing sites and as we speak we are
setting up new federal testing sites in
areas where there is increased demand
right now
right and i hear you but here is admiral
gerard about that very fact take a
listen
at the end of the trump administration
between september and december we did
180 million free tests the only reason
why we're in such a problem right now is
that the biden administration did not
invest in testing between january and
september this just didn't hit us
remember it's september with delta they
were testing shortages and they failed
to meet the mark on uh
improving the industry to provide the
test that people need
so just a response to that i'll move on
from testing
yeah so um just in the last year we now
have 13 fda authorized rapid tests eight
of them are in the market and it is
those rapid tests that we are relying on
now to increase this testing supply
we've done an extraordinary amount in
increasing the testing supply just in
the last year and again huge demand here
in the united states and also around the
world
okay uh this is bobby from tennessee she
has a question take a listen please
it seems like we have a lot of concern
about cases and
that's uh to be expected but uh we keep
hearing that it's very very mild uh
symptoms so
i'd like to just see a little more of
that addressed and how how concerned
should we be thanks
and this is about the the severity nick
has a similar question on twitter why
are we still focused on cases rather
than case to hospitalization ratio all i
read from omicron is
is it's not severe same kind of question
yeah really important questions we still
um more and more studies continue to
come in every single day about the
severity of omicron and we continue to
learn more
we also know with an increased number of
cases we are going to have some people
who have severe disease and so we are
watching both the severity as well as
the number of cases we do need to still
keep track of cases because they are a
leading indicator we know that our
hospitals get full several weeks after
our cases start to rise so we need to
keep a good line of sight on both and
let me just reiterate what we do know
about this virus about this variant
specifically is that if you are
vaccinated and if you are boosted you
have a much lower rate of ending up as a
severe case or ending up as a fatality
okay but just to be clear you have one
fatality that's listed as omicron is
that still true and and what about
hospitalizations tied to omicron do you
have a sense of that
yeah really important question so
certainly my heart go out to the family
of this case this fatality that we
learned of yesterday in texas and we are
still learning more about that case what
i can tell you right now is the vast
majority of people who are in the
hospital right now are unvaccinated and
so we are learning there still continue
to be people who are in the hospital
from our delta surge of course and we
are following um what the severity and
what is happening with the omicron
variant as well what i can also tell you
in in countries that have had a surge
before us we're in close touch with them
they are starting to report less
severity
and we are you know looking at how we
can apply the lessons that they have
learned the science that they have
learned on the backdrop that they have
and how it may be applied here in the
united states
i guess there are questions doctor about
the overall number the 800 000
deaths tied to covid one way or another
whether it's delta
one from omicron or the original covet
19 with all of those folks and
comorbidities do you have it broken down
pretty well
you know we can tell you some of the
demographics certainly with regard to
ages and and a lot of this is we're
working very closely with our states
and our local jurisdictions whose data
we rely on to bring it into the cdc so
that we can um compile it together and
look at it as a at the national level
but certainly what we are continuing to
learn as people who have severe disease
who are in the hospital are more likely
to be older patients more likely to have
comorbidities and certainly more likely
to be unvaccinated and in fact right now
i can tell you just data updated just on
friday has demonstrated that there's a
20 times increased risk of death
associated with covid if you're
unvaccinated compared to if you're
vaccinated and boosted
okay just a couple more quickly this is
lori ann
who writes why won't they talk about
natural immunity every other country
takes into account natural immunity why
don't we
you know we have that's a really good
question and
we have learned a lot about natural
immunity and we at cdc have recently
released a scientific brief to
demonstrate all that we know about
natural immunity what we can tell you
with omicron even with natural immunity
is that there's um
increased risk of re-infection with
omicron if you've been previously
infected compared to the prior variance
so even those with natural immunity we
are recommending that you get vaccinated
and get boosted and really what this is
telling us what omicron is telling us is
with a variant that has this many
mutations we need a really high level of
immunity and that means getting yourself
maximally vaccinated
but if you had
have omicron
and you get through it which most people
are
does that provide immunity for delta
or vice versa
yeah really important we're starting to
look at the studies now in the lab
that will try and inform the question of
the cross-reactive protection of delta
to omicron and in fact of omicron to
delta and those studies are just
emerging right now we do know that
there's less cross protection from prior
variants to omicron and the studies of
whether omicron will protect you from
from other variants those studies are
just emerging and then of course the
studies that are going to happen at the
population level in the clinical
situation are still emerging right now
okay last one this is dave joyce uh he
has a question about masks in schools
you have consistently cited one study in
arizona as justification for
mask mandates in schools yet there's
reporting in the atlantic that shows
that this study is deeply flawed will
you follow the science and stop relying
on faulty studies
and end mass mandates for children in
schools
response
um you know there have been study after
study not only in this country but in
other countries that have demonstrated
that our layered prevention strategies
including masks in schools are able to
keep our schools safely open
what i would say now is that we have the
capacity with vaccines available now to
children above the age of five that we
would encourage parents to get their
children vaccinated importantly we want
to be able to keep our schools open and
the best way to do that is to use those
layered prevention strategies and that
includes not only vaccinating our
children but and our adults but also to
continue to mask certainly in the
context of this hype very transmissible
omicron variant
and you have studies about the the
detriments of lockdowns and shutdowns
both physically mentally already right
those studies are underway we have seen
certainly the the challenges associated
with pandemic um mental health and our
challenges in our public health service
workers in our health care workers in
our children
over the last year and a half we we
understand the the deep um the deep
challenges associated with what this
pandemic has done
dr wolinski we really appreciate you
coming on and we'd love to have you back
to answer some more viewer questions
thanks for having me brent
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else